mais dans un cadre d'affrontements ou de
guerre larvée ou de guerre froide ou de
guerre contre le terrorisme
on sait ce que c'est de la garde contre
le terrorisme on a tendance pour
protéger sa population à vouloir les
espionner sans penser à mal
uniquement poillion pour je n'y crois
pas une seconde je ne crois pas à la
guerre contre le terrorisme le
terrorisme est une abstraction il ya des
actes terroristes et pour lutter contre
les actes terroristes
le meilleur moyen c'est pas le contrôler
dans la rue tous le monde c'est d'avoir
des gens qui font le boulot sur le
terrain qui se milices qui se faufilent
qui savent où aller
parce que nous avons eu dans le passé
des succès extraordinaires qui ont
rarement été dit à ses folies
d'espionnage général quand on voit qu'on
a installé dans paris des trucs pour
contrôler un quartier entier pardon mais
chez taddeï mais personne ne peut
prendre au sérieux une idée pareille 1
ce qui est à prendre au sérieux c'est
comme on enfile ses les moyens humains
j'ajoute pour la paix c'est exactement
de même nature faut la vouloir la paix
mais ya beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui qui
veulent la guerre les peuples n'ont pas
du tout le même rapport à la guerre
prenons la population des états unis
d'amérique n'a aucune idée de ce qu est
une guerre bien sûr elle a envoyé ces
jeunes gens en europe
elle les a envoyés au vietnam et les
envoyer dans toutes sortes de conflits
mais la population des états unis n'a
aucune idée de ce que c'est d'être
envahi comme nous l'avons été nous à
trois reprises par notre voisin car sa
cage et entière du territoire national
ils n'ont aucune idée de ce que ça a
coûté à la russie d'être envahi par les
nazis un ver millions de morts
ce sont des choses qui marquent les
peuples moi je sais que le peuple
français n'a pas les moyens de subir un
choc de cette nature par conséquent tout
ce qui va faciliter la paix repousser le
risque de guerre et de destruction
intérieur je pense par exemple aux
catastrophes qui pourraient surgir du
fait du nucléaire est bon pour le pays
donc nous on doit être les champions du
monde de la proposition de faire
fonctionner le unis plutôt que l'otan de
s'accorder avec ceux qui dans le moment
non pas la première place
aujourd'hui la première place les états
unis d'amérique à la fois s'entendre
avec le deuxième et le troisième
et puis qu'on ne se lasseront premiers
vont s'entendre avec les autres il faut
toujours donner à la france
la possibilité d'être libre de ses
mouvements
donc non alignés on est avec personne ça
paraît que tout le monde mais on sait ce
qu'on veut et ce qu'on ne veut pas moi
je ne veux pas de la guerre de l'espace
parce que nous la perdront séance
tenante
est ce que vous réalisez que les neuf
dixièmes des arts ne m'en matériel que
nous utilisons ou des moyens de
protection que nous avons 16 ohms une
seconde depuis l'espace vous comprenez
on peut de plus l'espace nous avons
toutes sortes d'activités humaines qui
dépendent de l'espace quatre pays savent
détruire depuis la terre un satellite
dans l'espace
les français aussi mais ils ne le disent
pas parce qu'ils sont hypocrites mais il
y en a quatre autres qui l'ont dit nous
savons le faire
heureusement nous aussi mais vous coupez
instantanément tous qui en dépend par
exemple votre gps de galileo doit
terminer va essayer de vous retrouver
maintenant vous avez plus l'habitude de
consulter les panneaux et tout ça bon je
vous donne cet exemple mais plein
d'autres combien de nos armements ne
fonctionne que parce qu'ils sont
interactifs c'est beaucoup plus efficace
de plonger la france dans le noir de
couper toutes ses centrales nucléaires
de leur approvisionnement d'interrompre
toute la lumière sur notre sur notre
pays que d'aller détruire quatre pauvres
chars dans une plaine ou dans un désert
c'est beaucoup plus efficace
militairement par conséquent il est à
peu près certain que l'indépendance de
la france repose à 90% sur sa capacité
d'intelligence qu'est ce qu'on est
capable de faire 1
et puis aussi d'avoir moins confiance
dans ceux qui se prétendent nos amis
parce qu'ils nous espionnent 1
et puis des fois on serait mieux
informés ça serait pas plus mal
[Musique]